Johanna is in Florida how do you feel
about giving monthly donations to groups
like World Vision while in baby step 2 I
could definitely use the $33 a month
towards debt but I also feel like we
made a commitment to help this child
well you need to pray through whether or
not you have made a commitment or a
contract at is there a zero are you
committed to do this for the rest of
your life is world vision a perpetual
commitment no it's not
and so you from you know you committed
to how you you sponsored a child but
there's not a timeframe on that to my
knowledge and it's a wonderful thing to
do obviously sponsor a child the general
guideline is this and you you can you
know just pray and and find what God's
Spirit is telling you to do in the
middle of this but the general guideline
is for those of us that are evangelical
Christians our baseline for giving
before we do anything else is the tithe
a tenth of our income off the top before
you do anything going to the local
church and that's a standard evangelical
belief in teaching for thousands of
years a couple thousand years ago and
fifteen hundred years or so and so and
it's modeled after an Old Testament
guideline in Deuteronomy that says to
give a tenth of your increase in
Deuteronomy 28 and the Old Testament
storehouse was where the widow's the
orphans and the Levites who were the
priests were taken care of it is the Old
Testament version of the New Testament
church and so you're in the local church
should be taking care of widows and
orphans and paying their preachers what
it amounts to and that's what the tithe
is to be used for and that was
reaffirmed by Christ in the New
Testament so if you're not an
evangelical Christian then this
discussion
but the way you ask this you ask it like
a person of faith so that's how I'm
gonna answer it okay never does God have
you to give to gain his favor he loves
you whether you give her whether you
don't give he says give because it makes
you into the kind of person I want you
to be I want to make you into a giver
God says and he starts that with that as
a tithe and he says to test him in this
test me it's the only time in the Bible
God says test me other than that testing
God's probably a bad idea
in the Bible this is one time he says to
do it in Malachi so test him try a tenth
then once you've done that anything
above the tithe in scripture is
considered an offering and the tithe is
off the top before you do anything
offerings come from surplus all
throughout scripture there's nowhere in
scripture that the offering above the
time does not come from surplus the only
time that's even close to that is a
description of the Widow's mite and you
know there's a whole lot of weird
teaching around that I can tell you but
anyway the there's nowhere in scripture
that God had people give above the tithe
when they were broke and so all of that
to say the world vision is an offering
it's not a tithe and that would be from
surplus you have debt you're broke you
don't have surplus and so you're taking
care of your own household first so
you're not worse than unbeliever when
you clean up your debts so that you can
be more generous later again ten percent
is just the baseline our goal is to
become wealthy so we can give away
millions of dollars to help people like
little children that need food and that
kind of stuff
and so you know generally speaking what
I did and what I tell folks to do not
with a legalistic mindset and not with a
prosperity gospel mindset but just
trying to follow the instructions in
Scripture is I'm going to tithe and not
do any offerings until I get out of debt
and build my emergency fund and then as
I start investing I
the offerings and do a lot of other
things above the tithe at that point but
at least tithe going through the first
three baby steps and after that then
you've taken care of your own household
you've laid a basic foundation for your
household then the strength the strength
that you've built allows you to be
gentle with others it's very difficult
to be gentle when you're weak and giving
is a type of gentleness it's a type of
compassion and you know you're that's
why you're struggling with it you're
weak right now financially it's like my
two-year-old granddaughter does not need
to carry around my eight week old
granddaughter she's not got the strength
to be gentle she'd be staggering under
the weight of that and might drop her on
her little head and that's the way this
feels it takes strength to be gentle
that not any problem at all for me to
hold that eight eight week old is it but
for that little toddler to hold that a
week old is difficult so what we're
trying to say is grow up financially so
that your giving is done out of strength
and that's where I would tell you to do
but you can do either one do whatever
you want to do and if God tells you to
do something else do something else and
this is not I'm not mad at World Vision
it's nothing to do with that this is
just a teaching about how to separate
your decisions about giving hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]